♪ (AMBIENT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
TEDROS:
You're the American dream.
Rags to riches.
Trailers to mansions.
You are fucking Jocelyn.
Just be you.
Easy. I'll just do that.
♪ (POP MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
SPEAKER: I'm
telling you right now,
these people in here
are gauging
whether or not you still got it.
I just wonder about
the strippers.
SPEAKER 2: They're kind of
out femme-ing her
with the flips and the dips
and the...
Gah Yah kat kat kats.
TEDROS: You're too distracted.
We need to block out
all the noise.
I'm sorry, who are you?
Now sing.
♪ Am I, am I, am I ♪
Woo!
SPEAKER 3: Do you feel this
right now?
Oh, no thank you.
(SCREAMING)
I think I just fell in love
with you.
What does that mean,
he's taken over the house?
SPEAKER 4:
He's brainwashed her.
-Hm?
-(LAUGHING)
-You're not a human being.
-(CHUCKLES)
You're a star.
♪ Am I, am I ♪
Never trust a dude
with a rat tail.
Woo!
♪ Am I, am I, am I, am I ♪